after getting rejected by traditional
media Andrew Schultz Akash Singh Mark
Gagnon and Alex media bet all in on
themselves what started as a sports
podcast appearing to be filmed in a
broom closet has since exploded into one
of the game's biggest and most
culturally relevant podcasts but how
these underdogs beat the system is just
one part of the story now that they're
on top is it all downhill from here how
do I want to process my time here and I
think that's what I'm thinking about
it's very likely I'll get to like a
dollar amount where I just where I might
I might stop everything this all started
way bizack in 2008 when a caution Andrew
met at a very glamorous gig in New York
he's one of the first guys I met we were
both doing this Hood room in Brooklyn
the show got canceled and I remember
back then I didn't know like the skinny
jeans was like fashion they're like look
at this door coming up here in skinny
jeans in a walk and then I was like but
he's doing a hood room in Brooklyn he
can't be like a dork for real so we
shook hands and then he asked me if I
wanted to ride back to the show because
the show got canceled right back to the
city to Manhattan and he was in a
minivan it was also so funny he and I
like not only had the same taste in
comedy we thought on a very similar
wavelength and then bits we were we
wanted to do comedy the same way and
their raw style of Comedy is what makes
flagrant so popular when everyone else
is being PC flagrant was the only voice
fighting against all that woke culture
in a time where it was literally the
most political correctness in history we
carved out a lane of flagrancy that did
not exist anywhere else the secret to
their success boils down to one thing
but the main thing was we need to put
the friendship over the podcast and this
camaraderie may seem obvious at first
but it's something they had to learn the
hard way before flagrant the show was
called flagrant 2 no easy buckets and it
was not easy at the time they had a
co-host named Kaz but you have an
amazing ability I have to I have to give
this up to you you have an absolutely
uncanny ability to show up the exact
amount of time late every episode I'm
here right now with Akash thing is Kaz
here no of course kazin isn't here why
would you show up to an episode
episode's out a little bit late today
yeah okay that's kaz's fault yeah that's
my bad guys but here's the thing it was
at this moment that he knew he up
so with Kaz Castaway the show evolves to
Andrew Schultz's flagrant with Akash
Singh and this is where the squad really
shines but first how did Mark and Alex
get here enter Mark Gagnon my plan is
that I was gonna be like hey can I sell
some merch I do some social media and
then let me open for you and it's been
called even he was like all right it
never was gonna work after hosting a
comedy show for Schultz in Orlando he
got invited up to New York to join the
squad and Mark's first appearance on
flagrant will forever stick in your mind
all right y'all know Mark you know very
funny young comic let's bring him on
tour he's in New York he was
Couchsurfing a little bit I'm like yo
I'm out of town you know what I mean why
don't you stay at my place dog you got
my place I come back from my little
vacay you know what I mean
I shower this morning before I come here
flagrant too what do I see on the bottom
of the shower not pubes
they've been stuck together ever since
and in true flagrant fashion Alex media
is at the back of the list
we're having fun huh I got lucky that
Andrew took a chance on me and this was
I don't know not too many people know of
this story but so Alex is not my real
name I it's uh just a name I go by
because I was in Social I mean I was in
law enforcement at the time and so I
didn't want those two worlds colliding
the name I picked Alex Anderson was a
comic that Andrew knew and so for the
first two weeks we were talking on DM he
thought he was talking to his friend but
there is more at play than just a lucky
DM Alex media's work ethic is next level
and he used to make fun of me because
it's like I have a Tesla and I would
have to test a drive like drive itself
and I'm editing on the wheel because
it's like nah I'm turning this
around right now and I'm gonna get this
clip back to you like ASAP and Alex
grinded like this for years while
balancing his day job until one day
Andrew made him an offer he couldn't
refuse to Al quit his job let's do a
little round of applause some clap for
Al basically I had a conversation with
Al and I you know I'm talking to you
about this archives and I said to Alex I
said this is what I want to do and I
need a guy who's going to be rocking
with me on this 100 I can't work around
your job do you want to do it do you
want to take the risk and the flagrant
fam was born but what makes them the
Avengers of Comedy is what most people
don't know about them before flagrant
Mark had years of experience working
with a media company and also producing
his own content getting millions of
views there's honestly not that much
info about him out there but you can get
a good taste of his media expertise by
checking out his YouTube Channel Camp
Gagnon Alex media owns WTF media Studios
that produces content for some of the
biggest podcasts in the game in Akash
sacrificed everything for this podcast
at one time almost going homeless we're
incredibly committed to this podcast you
know uh Akash went homeless for this
podcast you know he literally gave
everything Akash has also been willing
to put in the work building his own
stand-up fan base case following the
Schultz social media model of releasing
his own clips and specials and now
selling out tours even behind the scenes
their editor Shifty DM Schultz and then
moved to New York City with 25 bucks oh
and fun fact this guy's name is Dov he's
Andrew's manager and producing partner
who also just so happens to be his first
friend from college so when I say
flagrant fam that is exactly what they
are flagrant is a crew of creators
willing to do whatever it takes to
create their own success and this is the
blueprint comedians are now following
like Matt Rife who followed Schultz's
formula and crashed Ticketmaster and
just for you I made a video about it
right there
go and click it click click click
[Music]